mine is about babies and birthdays we're  gonna start with birthday wishes  today going out to Royal baby Archie  today Prince Harry and Megan's son is  one years old can you believe that he  was just born a year ago to celebrate a  new video was released this morning  here's a look we're going to read duck  rabbit good job hey look a duck it's not  a duck that's a rabbit yeah can you turn  the page that's Harry behind the camera  and if you listen closely you can hear  him say Bravo at the end this new video  is part of a charity campaign for Save  the Children the group aims to improve  the lives of millions of children around  the world